the other waiting the overwatching
payment of Alden that was deductions and
then income so things like
superannuation they get taken out of my
way your salary so being that it gets
taken out that's why we call it a
deduction right now some of the
deductions are more important the others
health insurance so that we looked at in
detail yesterday superannuation is the
one when we're going to look at today
just some of your receipt yesterday also
else it wasn't that knows what's like a
one-sentence definition of super good
what is money for retirement
now money for this is important to
notice and you can kind of see this in
the question though I slice off part of
it if you work then your employer is of
life you pay money into super regulation
for you it is over and above what
actually cover so if you have you know X
amount of dollars per hour
they don't take some of that out and
then use that for superannuation you
have your X amount of dollars per hour
and then they've got to pay extra and
that's important is a big distinction
there which I'm going to lay out as we
go to this question so as we've been
doing without all that fun a tremendous
questions let's stop like any important
details down and then we're gonna start
to look at the questions and what
they're asking for us to do with those
dollars so first we've got a salary Paul
has an annual salary that's his annual
income there so I'm going to write five
six your
that's how much she's actually okay
his employer pays it just kind of gets
constant Fu just like a big reveal his
employer pays nine percent super
graduation that's what I'm saying easy
okay so I'm going to call that employer
contribution that's like how much they I
do okay
so nine percent is the employer
contribution
now that I cut off because I zoomed in
and I would not say you do my demo is
that in addition to his employer paying
that extra bit which he can't access
some retirement he decides to also put
in some money of his own okay and that's
what this bit because off says Paul pays
four percent of his income himself right
so that's something he wasn't obliged to
do he just charged okay so being that's
something that that's T's what he's done
himself we call that at three percent we
connect a personal contribution
sometimes it's the textbook doesn't tend
to use this language but those
real-world does so you guys should go
back sometimes this is called a
contribution right so it's like yeah you
guys are putting it out and I'll put it
in the neck as well and sometimes the
government will honor that because
they're like yeah thumbs up the same
okay that's all the information in the
question requires so we're going to take
that and we're now going to try and
answer these one two three four parts so
but it how much superannuation is paid
on paws behalf okay now we can that word
II can't believe on Paul's bahut which
of these display
yeah it's the employer community to the
nine percent okay so the PAS a all I
need to say is Omaha the employer
contribution like the actual dollar
amount
there it's not a Mexico it's like
percent all that and you can come that's
all the need to calculate sir
as has been the theme of this whole
topic really the maths of this the
operations are no hard they're not
complicated
what is cheeky is the interpretation and
knowing what to do with the right now
can someone grab the captain editorial
that number is five thousand forty eight
in the twenty eight five zero four zero
two forty eight point two eight great so
isn't it and can I emphasize in fact if
you have another color then you should
emphasize it with me like this is the
employment page so it's over and above
these salary okay it's not a lot of a
salary it's extra okay so I'm going to
write that under God and above self
so I've got that time papi how much just
all contribute so this is his own of the
free world he's decided I'm gonna pay a
little bit extra okay so I've got here
the personal contribution
okay now I hope you can see right what
is the personal contribution is just
going to be I'm going to go ever the
same person s but instead of nine
percent it's going to be one percent you
go ahead and do that gave you cut that
out and tell me what that number is
I didn't this is a new one
it is said you could look any village
yeah they were favorited to us it's the
Atmos it's the classic example tax give
me what yeah yeah
what do you guys hear about arrowroot
III I was okay and someone got this is
what percent has some about another for
me 43 and 60 attends eat Nicola okay now
forbidden how saying these two things
are different employer contribution and
person transmission they function
differently in regard to his total
income this is not the employer paying
for you this is not over and above
salary this is coming out of these
sentences from his salary so please just
like we did before mock that because I'm
gonna do different things with this
number because it's a different kind of
number so I'm gonna write that that's
wrong the salary he pays himself
now let me just pause for a minute and
just ask a question to you like why
would you do this why would you like
this amount is already being taken now
you don't have a choice about that why
would you go ahead and pay more you know
it was a study done that said if um if
people has it filling out their life you
know they superannuation what should I
introduce if people look at a photo of
themselves that's like it didn't age but
it was they actually paid more because
they did so it's an actual excitement
effect I want you to put an important on
an exodus if you put in a mixer for 15%
I'll explain in a second teach one last
question
now 15 percent what is the relevance of
this don't let me explain remember I
begin this lesson by saying
superannuation for looking at this
because it is a client of starts of the
date become what it is it's a deduction
right just like health insurance just
like manager space bond on earth so
these kinds of things will reduce your
income importantly they'll reduce your
taxable income so if it gets deducted
out of your pay you don't have to pay
tax that's income tax right now fifteen
percent still allows you to write down
this is the text that he is going to
have to tape on this amount right 50
percent it sounds like a lot doesn't it
except it's not this this are the these
are the current tax rates 2015-2016 taxi
because you guys know utilize by the
interview now I just want you to
carefully look at the tax rates right
can you see like this is the lowest tax
bracket if you're earning between
eighteen thirty seven thousand you're
going to get taxed nineteen cents for
each dollar that means nineteen percent
does that make sense
ninety percent over that amount that's
how much you need tax as you move up the
percentage just increases right thirty
two and a half percent thirty-seven
percent and forty five percent okay now
that's our forty five percent of your
total income when we look at income
taxable I kind of need we're gonna talk
about exactly how to calculate that you
made a bit of a party but my point is
just to make this comparison look at
these numbers and then look at this
number right do you see there's a huge
benefit to sort of if you're willing to
surrender a bit of money in the short
term you don't get that tax on it you
just get this tiny tax on that but it's
almost like you're not paying tax at all
so that's why people do it some people
do country
contributions and in fact in addition to
this sometimes the government will say
you know what if you give $1,000 we'll
just give another thousand dollars until
super for free like so long as you put
that in now put it in that matter is so
serious that trying to encourage same
time
yeah yeah that's right so what they try
to reward is like delay gratification
but most people are not gonna do most
people like quick I need to have as much
money accessible I can't extend it but
they won't use whatever to think you can
come from the government just like I got
this from the government but it does
vary from you but generally it's an
amount like this and it's an amount that
is certainly lower than all forms of
income tax because that's the whole
accepted body I do say this number
pigmentosa pickles one more thing we
don't need to worry about this 15% on
calculations for now now we just try to
work out the Zumba theme but when we
look at text light on like okay let's go
back to other questions so sorry
okay so now we can return let's have a
look on Part C asks for us
plus a what is Polycom let's see
superannuation contribution okay so I'm
going to write this as income less soup
so this is on the super particular now
this is where having written these bits
in red and treating these contributions
differently this is where this is
helpful to us we know that if income
starts here right so I'm going to write
down that P there are six thousand
number and I know something has to get
subtracted these are the contributions
right but they don't both get subtracted
do you see why this is new you're going
to subtract because it's or involve this
it's completely separate from this no
mom okay so that doesn't get touched
this Hillier is the number that he has
paid okay so this is going to be
subtracted so there's my two two four
three and sixty eight cents and that's
going to give me his actual income of
the contributions have been done okay
what is that
do you really something
in 1848
okay okay so you see he's a little bit
wet off he's not that much more so like
this some time has been paid in addition
to his salary all right lost it and
again pastry carefully and understand
how we're gonna use these them as
dancers what's the total amount pay
employees superannuation fund okay now
I'm just thinking about what goes into
the fund over to these numbers go into
the phone they come from different
places one comes from use employment and
one comes from him but they both ending
up in the same Club does that make sense
so I'm going to call this total you can
call it total contribution but I guess
also a survivor
to the contribution and I'm just simply
going to add both these numbers that's
what's going to end up in the plan right
that looks like
it's gonna be like I'm dying right
somewhat efficient stop rough for me
okay so again the masses are hot all be
doing is like multiplying and adding but
people frequently get these wrong in
terms of like weight but which things do
I subtract which things am I going to
include in this total contribution so
it's like three carefully put in three
words be verbal and explain what the
numbers are so they do not get confused
okay